I'm curious a mark or Catherine how did
you find this story or did this story
find you in the 60s this was actually a
pretty prominent story obviously 67 you
have the rebellion in Detroit and then
also Newark and but over the course of
50 years it was largely forgotten and
somebody in my production company named
Hugo Lindgren told me about the story
and it's one of many things we were
looking at but what really turned it
into a screenplay was I went up to
Detroit in the end of 2014 and met with
two people who kind of changed my life
one was Larry Reid who Algie Smith at
plays and I sat in his living room and
he hadn't he hadn't talked about he
hadn't talked about what happened to him
that night in 50 years at the time his
dad had told him never to talk about it
and it was the first of many
conversations but it was a very moving
encounter for me and then I also met
Melvin does moocs on the same trip and
that to John boyega plays and Melvin is
or is like a football player in his side
he's a giant guy he's huge and even
though he's lesbian to 70s he's still
really anyway big dude sitting in his
dining room and he just started crying
as he was telling me this story of how
he was kind of trapped between two
worlds so that's how it started just
from wanting to tell the stories of
those people and then the kind of the
other themes that you mentioned you
cover the sort of civil rights and
racial strife stuff kind of came after
that but it started with those people
you're from one of those places that
sees on a daily basis what happens in
police departments
we're living 50 years later in a world
where it's almost deja vu let's bring it
home well my dad always said if you do
the same thing you're going to get the
same results and I think as a time and
as a people it's it's this movie is is
poignant and important because if you
look at the diversity of the production
team and you look at the diversity of
the cast and we were able to tell this
story in a true honest way and no actors
were hurt in the filming of it see for
yourself so the reality of it is one bad
apple shouldn't spoil the bunch and you
know a movie like this a story like this
is not pointing a finger at the the
awful nature of the police department is
pointing a finger at the awful nature of
the lack of humanity of a certain few
and those certain few aren't worthy of
wearing that uniform and pendant on that
badge
[Applause]
Catherine you made this movie or you say
you've made this movie and and I believe
you because you want a discussion about
race that has not been made here are
people going to discuss it now is this
the switch I certainly think it was that
was a there was a key motivator because
it was when Mark and I first discussed
it was right around the time of the
Ferguson Missouri when the decision not
to indict the officer and and I found
that the story was extremely moving and
it was 50 years ago yet it was also
today and then of course potentially
tomorrow and I you know I immediately
thought this was an opportunity to
certainly expose
this inequity yet again and and you know
shine a light maybe a little bit of
light can go a long way that was my hope
this film has action it has stillness
it has exhalation how do you bring all
that together as a filmmaker and the
pacing of a film I have an extraordinary
crew I mean really it's not as everybody
knows in this room no one person makes a
movie and between an incredible cast in
my humble opinion a phenomenal
cinematographer and Barry Ackroyd a
phenomenal editor in William Goldenberg
and and the opportunity to work with
this extraordinary content and start
with the macro the you know the lead-up
to rebellion in a very kind of a time
that was in the midst of a perfect storm
which we're probably still in today of
course and and then begin to winnow it
down to the human beings from that are
at the heart of it and humanize the
situation that's extremely difficult for
any most people to to understand or even
to imagine and then out of that perhaps
the potential for empathy and out of
empathy
you know there's awareness and so you
know I think if the purpose of art is to
agitate for change then you know this is
kind of I don't know the purpose of this
piece what was your takeaway John um how
do we live with this as an audience
that's a deep question I don't have an
answer to I mean I was questioning I was
sitting there like what do I do I do
with this I mean I think one thing about
about watching this movie is that you
you you it's one of those movies are
very unique in its time because we are
living in the time in which the content
which the narrative exists today and if
you just take out the the clothes from
the 60s a bit of the culture and just
you know 2017 it could have happened
last week in fact it couldn't happened
in in London we've we've had we have
serious issues now with Greville PI up
the fire and grateful tower with a
recent black kid who was now a wrestle
to the floor and died 24 hours later and
it just reflects on on our world in in a
very tragic way but but I do think it
motivates a conversation that could
could lead to change but it's part of as
an internal individual thing yeah
absolutely I think earlier you know you
asked why we wanted to be involved in
this project and I think the potential
to be part of a film that can initiate
such a critical and and much-needed
conversation add to the progression and
the good work that is being done because
you know there are people out there
working hard to improve race relations
you know eliminate racially motivated
police work you know it's not as though
nothing has been done at all but if we
are looking back at a film that is set
50 years ago and we are seeing a
repetition of the same events in 2017
it's clear we're not doing enough we
cannot afford to have racist individuals
operate in society period it's totally
irresponsible to allow those individuals
any sort of power and it makes
absolutely no sense to have them become
a member of a community of people whose
job it is to serve and protect a
community of people so
so that I think is something you know
the motivated all of us to want to be
involved in in this film and and I must
also say as well that you know that is
something that Kathryn Bigelow does as
an artist she recognizes the importance
of our leading to change and impacting
society positively and it's a call to
all artists to do our bit as creatives
to make sure that our work actually
stands for something
entertainments great but change is
that's that's where it's at
oftentimes those kinds of movies though
aren't greenlit automatically how do you
get a movie like Detroit greenlit come
on girl I know I know a guy actually I
know a woman I mean yeah I've heard a
lot to do okay yeah we had a
conversation and we're fortunate enough
to be supported by Annapurna who really
Megan Ellison who thought highly of this
project and and we're very fortunate to
have that kind of support and confidence
in it she got behind it that's an
understatement
yes that doesn't happen very often that
someone comes along and drops that kind
of money and single-handedly pushes it
forward what did you say to her
I think she believed in the story and
you know she really genuinely believed
in it so that was that was the biggest
motivator and kanai's something of that
which I think a lot of people don't talk
about it and it just kills me in my face
Kathryn is a talented educated
well-rounded beautiful white woman
and when you see that you expect in this
generation for people of that esteem to
do movies about young beautiful white
women because that's all she can do
that's all she knows that's the only
story she can tell but the reality of it
is the cream always rises to the top and
if two beautiful well-rounded young life
women get together and make this movie
who's to tell them that they can't do it
with storytelling
we're artists so why is it now if you
know if you make a movie about a young
black dude from the wall and you only
can direct it if you're a black dude
from New Orleans that's crazy that's
preposterous you put limitations on your
goals dreams and abilities and reasons
for being in this business with
storytellers tell stories just to add a
little bit I don't I mean I surely don't
know how projects get green lives so
don't ask me but but I can say this
though you say it doesn't happen a lot
and I just say but a flight this project
there's just some stuff that's just so
people like to talk about this either
but there's so spiritual that you just
can't put a finger on it and it's like
this project was bigger than any of us
and so I feel like there was no one
person that honestly could stand in the
way of this story being sold and I think
it's because of the time of it and
because of the the souls that would be
touched by and the way people would feel
coming away from it like this project
will do something that then be more than
a movie you know what I'm saying like
people are already walking out of there
is like I just can't I don't have words
and that's that's like that's the
conversation started right there when
you don't have words and we can finally
sit down and say okay now what do we say
how do we move on from it